that look on your face on me this was
priceless
i'm mad at you well i mean you as your
sister you
and the person who hates you marry you
i understand no listen to me
i feel hurt i feel let down i feel like
slapped in the face
and just totally neglected the one
person you know you can always depend on
is me
your whole life and you can't text hi
to me i'm okay something simple is i'm
okay but the point of the matter is is
that i'm where i'm i'm okay
why would i take care of myself but yeah
your jotter needs you right now
is just kicked to the wayside the last
two years first i want to make sure i'm
good
before i go see them and that's why i've
been trying to reach out to them since
we've been out of rehab or in rehab
but it hasn't been successful
no maybe because you just totally
neglected
your kids i have to get myself better
and i feel like i
am in a good place right now i don't
think we're coming back to georgia for a
little while
so what are you going to do by alana
you're just going to kick your teenage
daughter out of your life oh
um you know she chooses to come to
florida that's fine
um and hopefully like we can be able to
talk
and work things out and
know that this is where i need to be at
right now
southeast florida is a huge part of our
recovery
i work with four rehabs um i take weekly
drug tests
um i mean i'm glad you're doing better i
am glad you're not done drugs
no okay i haven't even thought about it
i haven't
i don't tell you how many messages i've
sent you don't answer you don't call you
don't text
she thinks everything's back to sunshine
and unicorns
no it's not how it works she has a lot
of repairing to do